Would you date a conservative?
No. No, no, no.
Why not? Yeah,
cause I don't hate myself.
Oh, my god.
Like that. I think he's like.
I mean, I don't think he's a conservative,
but like, that was.
That's the rule. I'm a big on my values and morals,
and conservatives
values and morals typically don't align with that of mine.
I really value the people that I date
and I want them to value me the same way.
And I think that politics is very personal
and for me, I really have a hard time separating the two.
For me to really love someone and for me to feel like I love them,
I feel like we have to rely on certain things,
for certain morals for our relationship to work.
That's a hard line for me.
I just couldn't marry someone
that would consciously vote against everything that I stand for
and my existence. That's a hard no, no.